Mike: One of the things we commonly, as security
consultants, train developments teams for-
and architects and other folks in the creation
of software- is threat modeling.
And, that's where we kind of just go through
a brainstorming exercise and we think of all
the threats that exist against what we're
trying to create, and think about how the
application can be attacked.
How can it be compromised?
And if these attacks are successful, what
does it mean against the bottom line?
How much is it going to cost us if a certain
attack results in a breach of some sort of
data?
Pete: So, that's threat modeling and there's
also the concept of modeling out abuse cases
as well, right?
Not just a use case, but-
Mike: Right.
An abuse case.
Pete: Many developers don't think in terms
of an abuse case.
What would a malicious person, someone with
malicious intent, do?
How would they walk through the application,
how could they potentially turn it on itself.
Mike: Right.
So, a use case might be- we need to let the
user enter their credentials and store them
permanently or semi-permanently.
An abuse case for that would be- well, a third
party application exists on the device, the
device is jailbroken and it spiders the filesystem
and finds this file containing our user's
credentials.
Pete: Or an attacker trying to abuse the forgot
password feature to try to gain access to
an account in an unauthorized way.
Mike: Exactly.
So, the point being- we do the threat modeling,
as known as, like a risk assessment.
We figure out- OK, what is our true risk here?
Then, we can kind of make a decision.
Like, OK, maybe it's OK to store these credentials,
it's just for our gaming platform.
But, when we say, OK, this is an ecommerce
site, and the credentials can be used to potentially
access credit card data for our customer,
maybe it's not worth it for us to store these
credentials on the device.
So, I really think that it's important that
developers and other folks involved in the
creating of software, they really think about-
what does the application need to do, and
what are the risks inherent with that?
And then if they decide, you know what?
The risk is acceptable to us.
We'd like to store the credentials on the
device.
Then, they need to understand what secure
mechanisms exist on the platform that will
allow them to do that.
Pete: And this would be platform specific,
right?
Mike: Platform specific, correct.
Pete: Well, if I'm a developer and I'm trying
to get used to this concept.
Maybe this concept of creating abuse cases
is a little bit new to me.
How do I get started writing an abuse case
for my app?
I guess basically, think like a hacker.
Mike: Yea.
Pete: Any other tips or tricks, in order to
help somebody think about how to come up with
malicious ways to circumvent auth or do the
nasty things inside an application?
Mike: Yea, it really is- you have to put your
bad guy hat on and just start to really think
outside of the box.
And, that could be pretty hard for you to
do just sitting at your desk by yourself.
So, it can be a fun exercise to get the whole
team involved and even potentially bring in
a security guy to just give a talk.
Or even a little more in depth, a 45 minute
presentation of threat modeling and giving
you a mock threat model.
We really open your eyes and get you thinking
in a different way, which is what you need
to do if you need to kind these flaws before
they come to exist in your app.